this podcast and every other podcast on
my channel are brought to you by my
patreon where you can get versions ad
free and we are currently only 80
patrons away from a second podcast just
like this one called voice acting 101.
if you would like to support the
production of these podcasts and
potentially submit guest requests or
questions for future episodes go to
patreon.com otherwise this podcast will
be available on youtube and podcast
services on the second monday of every
month completely for free this one is
publishing on the third day of this
month i'm aware but going forward it
will be the second monday of every month
hello everyone i'm alana and today i am
joined by two wonderful people we have
mary this way
and manny down here uh both of whom are
video game writers like me um mary who
do you work for what games have you
worked on for your introduction
uh i work at insomnia games i'm
currently on the wolverine team i was
recently on spiderman miles morales and
before that i worked on walking dead the
final season and batman the enemy within
while i was at telltale games so
basically like a bunch of indie titles
nobody's ever heard of yeah nobody's
heard of anybody google them later
that's fine
yeah i wallow in obscurity
uh manny how about you hi
uh yes uh manny i work for respawn
entertainment i
did uh wrote for titanfall titanfall 2
star wars reddit fallen order and apex
legends
also never heard of any of them
absolutely startups
yeah lots of tiny little games they'll
you'll see them maybe at indicate or
something i don't know
um so i wanted to ask you guys i have a
whole bunch of questions and we can be
as candid with this as you want but the
first question i want to ask say say i'm
somebody who just wants to get into
video game writing um what's the one
piece of advice that you feel either
helped you the most or that you wish you
had known when you started out as a
video game writer
never heard that question
i keep it niche
um
i think it's that you have to have a
healthy interest in video games
overall like you can't just be someone
who has played one or two and loves them
which is my go-to style as a person but
you have to have this overall interest
so that you could
be a writer or a designer or an artist
whatever it is that you want to do but
uh specifically for writers so that you
can plug in anywhere you understand
different genres and different types of
games so you need to kind of make your
interest broader and you need to be
interested in more than just the writing
of games because what we do is
so tied to the design and to the art and
that you know there's just so much so
many departments that we touch so um
trying to develop your interests in all
of game making and different types of
games not just you're not always going
to get to write on something that you
love it doesn't it doesn't work that way
and i think that's the thing that's
really hard is trying to figure out how
to care about something you don't care
about
and that's absolutely a part of a job is
you have to really deeply care about
something that you might be like no i
don't care about this at all i had to do
that in university they made me write a
rom-com
because i openly said i didn't care and
so when i was doing my screenwriting
class they were like i want to read this
you know what
i actually do kind of like i ended up
writing a rom-com about a guy who has
really bad anxiety that leads him to
basically rule out anyone that he's
dating before the before they even get
far enough like that's great yeah he
asked someone a question that was like
you know uh how do you feel about having
kids and she was like i don't know and
he was like great we're on different
wavelengths goodbye so i like he had
like all these like this checklist that
the perfect girl had to meet um in part
because like that's how his brain worked
as someone with with anxiety anyway i'm
not gonna we're gonna do a live stream
that's what this 101 course is
but it was hard um manny and do you feel
that the same way like you obviously at
respawn have to work on a bunch of
different properties
yeah um uh
it's interesting i love what mary said
about the other uh departments because i
think that is a
thing that i didn't quite know about
when i first joined um and got into the
industry in that sort of culture but
something i lean heavily on it's there's
the positives and negatives right
there's like oh we gotta explain designs
silly ideas uh that are incredible uh
and then on the other side it's like
they are incredible ideas and they're
very fun and the art is beautiful and
the animations are beautiful so um i see
a lot of uh i have friends that are not
into the gaming world who will see job
postings and they're like oh i
love to do that
and i and although i know they're really
great writers i look at the people who
follow us online who will ask the
question how do you get into game
writing and i know they follow us
because we are in the gaming industry
and i'm like you're already so far ahead
of my friend who is a very uh
a good writer for tv and film because
i think you understand a bit more stuff
in regards to gaming that my friend may
not
understand or or my friend might think
that it's just pop in write a couple of
scenes and then you're good and then you
leave whereas i it's really like you're
built into this world you're trying to
develop and grow and and create your uh
your your niche you're trying to create
your sort of like um
you know career path out of it i want to
be a video game writer it's not just i
want to just write for this for a minute
and then write for that for a minute
which i don't know uh
people can do sometimes but it is a lot
more actively cross um departmental
in that you do actively often work with
design like at the same time you're
working on one thing whereas any of the
writers rooms that i have done that are
pertained to animation or tv don't work
that way at all uh it is the writer's in
a room and then you hand it off to
somebody else who figures everything out
whereas video games are constantly
collaborative from the jump so that's
that's also probably a skill it's like
you have to be able to work with other
teams you have to be okay with no i
imagine on a property like star wars
not that marvel's any different either
to be fair but you have to like adhere
to loads of rules and it's like i mean
santa monica studio has has a ton of law
but thankfully there's no like higher
disney god being like no
thor must be thin
we don't have to worry about that that
was definitely challenging but i didn't
have to deal with that too much i think
uh erica trieris and like stig were the
ones who were dealing with lucasfilm and
megan fausti when uh uh they were
working on that i didn't have to talk to
lucasfilm that much what i ended up
writing did get notes from them but
there wasn't like game stoppers because
a lot of the flags have been planted and
agreed upon from lucasfilms that was
really kind of nice for me but i can't
imagine how it was for them and and
whatever
you go through with marvel mary i don't
know if you do or don't i would say my
experience with marvel has been great
because most of it is just we go to them
and say you know we have this idea we're
interested in these themes here are the
comics that we've read these are the
things that we're interested in and they
say great here's 18 other
recommendations here's a behind the
scenes look do you want to talk to the
person that wrote it you know it really
it's awesome yeah yeah it's kind of it's
just a two-way street that's like
having another set of leads um in a way
that's just you're just talking to more
people about your ideas um it really
hasn't
it it is not so much the you know
seeking out the rubber stamp or like the
hammer of god coming down
you can't do this in your script it's
much more
we all want to make something really
cool so what are our ideas what is your
deep knowledge what do you know about
fans what do we know about fans which is
kind of a knowledge share but um i
really enjoyed it i think the
collaboration note
is a really important one especially in
triple a um i'm actually i'm teaching a
narrative design class for the first
time ever cool
and a big thing that i keep like
hammering is like if you don't want to
work closely with other people
that's fine but triple a is not going to
be it like that's that's not going to
work for you because we are constantly
talking all the time we're in meetings
all the time
um you need to get people excited about
your ideas you need to get excited about
other people's ideas that's just
it's so important games are too big to
be one person in a room writing all
those scripts like it just it's just not
it's not gonna work i think at every job
that i've had as a writer
which totally applies to my current job
i've had to block out time on my
calendar to not have meetings which
seems like such a funny thing that you
have to do that it just totally is a
reality is like you don't just sit in
your apartment and write all day it's
mostly meetings and you have to be like
i need this two hours to be undisturbed
so i can write
you have to wrangle that away from
people and i mean it's a lot of fun but
that's definitely a reality it's like
yeah you could be hired as a writer but
you want right all the time you'll spend
a lot of time talking to people and
pandemic makes it harder because zoom is
so easily accessible i would say maybe
for at least for our my experience it's
like oh can you talk right now or can
you talk right now like i'm fighting
like
my i have no excuse to not show up to
the meeting because i'm yeah you know
it's like oh i forgot it that was my
office in another meeting or something
like that when i was in the office but
now it's like
just click the link yep or somebody just
calls you and you're like yeah
like i'm technically on the clock i have
to hit yeah yeah yeah it's definitely a
thing and it's like it's hard to figure
out that work life balance but that i
feel like probably just pertains to
this year which somehow isn't 20 20
anymore i'm still recovering from the
fact that it's almost 20 22.
um but i was also going to ask you know
you guys both have worked on on huge
very popular ips where do you actually
start like what is the the beginning of
writing a star war or writing
a spider-man like where do you even
begin
do you want to go first man
well my my i haven't worked on a big ip
from the beginning necessarily for
fallen order i was doing apex and fallen
order at the same time
because i wanted to
because i was asked to help out on
fallen order while i was doing apex and
at the time i was
one of two writers for apex and uh but i
still really was like oh i want him
right source that's super cool so when i
did finally come on board for star wars
it was already like i mentioned yeah
yeah yeah yeah
gone through yeah i was giving notes on
stuff so uh so um that was nice to see
that journey and be a part of that but
for the most part i had no ownership of
it so i was just kind of helping until i
was actually brought on board to write
scenes
and even then like there's a lot of
stuff like flags put in place but it was
not like uh
start from the ground up type of
situation yeah but there were story
lines that i wanted to grab a hold of
and carry to the finish line and uh like
the relationship between cal and and and
bd1 and then like uh and the story and
breeze's character storyline like stuff
like that that i was like super
gravitated towards that hadn't had a lot
of work done so it was mostly like i
would write a one-page bio of or uh just
one sheeter of like hey here's what how
i think like cal and bd1 can work when
they first meet what bd1 story is what
could happen to him uh and in the game
is that he has his sort of memories are
replaced by these uh logs from his
previous owner so he doesn't know that
these logs are talking to bd1 throughout
the journey until this climactic moment
where he finally gets to understand what
he did yeah sorry spoilers
but that sort of journey in a one pager
i was like hey this is a cool idea and i
passed it off to aaron and stigg and
meghan and then they pass off to
lucasfilm and then it comes back and
everything gets approved and now we
actually have to do the thing and it's
like how the hell let me do that well i
would die for bd1 so you did a great job
i would too
again was a big part of that as well we
were both very much in love with bd1
he's adorable very cute still upset
there's no action figure actually
i have the uh
yeah uh i have the pop toy but that's
what they had a pop final i i mean i
have cows lightsaber which is also
awesome oh yeah super cool disneyland
right no no it was a it was a press
thing yeah
i had to fight for that one though i was
like
how many do you have we wanted these
but mary uh how how about you like where
do you oh my god that's such a long
cable he has that is i did not expect
you to be able to get that far
wow there we go yeah
oh it even has beauty one little baby
beauty one that's very cute
very cute
no please anytime yeah mary where do you
start on on any of the franchises that
you've worked on yeah so i mean the the
internet is my friend uh i usually start
with just your your basic google search
is like okay what are the iconic what
are considered the iconic uh comics or
movies or you know what whatever for
this character um and just inhale all of
those as quickly as i can read read all
the iconic books read all of the iconic
you know watch the movies watch whatever
i can it is time for an ad break which
is one that i actually really personally
am quite invested in um but of course if
you want to skip ads you can do so by
subscribing to patreon so i wanted to
take the opportunity to tell you all
about the video game accessibility
awards delivered by pizza hut this is a
show that i personally uh produce and
write and direct and put a whole lot of
time and love into now with the help of
a whole bunch of other people um of
course the show is proudly featuring
ablegamers steve spahn is my partner in
all of this helps me make every decision
and has been so important to the
creation of the show we are also working
with real good touring to help with all
of our production needs and the show
this year is sponsored by the lovely
people at pizza hut it is an award show
that will be airing on march 12
2022 on youtube.com charalazad and
several more to be announced outlets and
it is all about celebrating games that
are taking huge and very important
strides in the name of accessibility i
know that sounds very serious but the
whole thing will be a whole lot of fun
with a real focus from me on a good
sense of humor so stay tuned for more
information and a very big thank you to
pizza hut ablegamers and real good
touring for working with me on the show
this year
again it will be airing on march 12th
2022. um and that just kind of gives me
really good grounding in the character
you know it's not usually where i'm
pulling story lines or themes or plots
but it does give me a sense of like what
did other writers do with this character
what are things that they started to do
but then maybe didn't finish what are
things that they
maybe sort of introduced or at least i
spun off on it so that that tends to be
where i go and then the other thing is
um
until now i mostly worked on sequels
which is great in a way because i could
say okay what are all the themes that
they had in the first game that we can
then
build on so for example um with
spider-man the first spider-man game you
know is kind of about pete learning to
work with other people and in miles we
could invert that a little bit miles
already knows how to work with people
he's great at that but he needs to learn
to be his own spider-man because he's
new to all of this so we we could kind
of play off the themes that had already
been established and that's just fun for
me i like i like working on sequels
because you can just take a theme and
then springboard it a little bit
yeah starting from scratch i imagine
like i've you know i've not done it it's
gotta be a nightmare i've also done that
uh too even with big-ips although i
can't talk about them because it's nba
stuff i worked on years ago but um still
nba somehow but
in that case it really was like the the
iconic like comics and yeah
and everything really just helps like
what were what did what were people
excited about with this character well
yeah
you relate to them and then you throw it
all in the trash and then you go in a
completely different direction the last
jedi baby
absolutely
well manny apex is not an existing ip
that's true um tell me about working on
apex legends well as said previously i
imagine it's very easy multiplayer game
no stress whatsoever yeah um it is a it
is a non-stop roller coaster of trying
to get stuff into the game that works it
actually when we started it was probably
a little easier and we had a smaller
team it was it was really it was me and
and uh moa lobby and we're the only
narrative team uh and it was when we had
just come off of titanfall 2 and we're
trying to
explore what new stuff we want to do
while our multiplayer player team
started building on the battle royale
and that's when we kind of
played it and realized how fun it is but
the best thing is is that we wanted to
fit that into the world of titanfall so
it kind of is an existing ip but it was
an existing aip that we created so it
had actually been leaked to me funnily
enough apex had been leaked
yeah by somebody who had a bar without
it as titanfall 3.
so
yes and when it was announced as apex i
was like this yeah this is the same
same game
which i just assumed that
i don't know meant that they were
happening at the same time but i won't
force any of that conversation onto you
naturally
i mean we basically wanted to launch it
day one just without any sort of build
up or promotion because
it was the wand of titanfall sequel but
this was not that and we wanted people
to play it before we wanted um the the
questions to come out we wanted to be
like just play it right now and it's
really cool and people are like yeah we
love it uh so that was kind of like what
we sort of worked on but that's a really
good idea actually because you're right
because people would have been like
you're making a battle royale instead of
titanfall but then they played it and
now i mean it's my favorite battle
royale i love it oh nice
i'm only saying that because you're here
i know
uh and i thank you either way um
the uh but story-wise that basically
made us need to create characters and
create this lore and build this world
that is in the world titanfall connected
to it but isn't um the same toys that
you would get in a multiplayer for
titanfall so
um that's when we started developing
actual characters at first we were
calling our characters classes and that
was like the biggest problem i had at
the beginning was that the reason why
i'm here is so i can be a writer and
write stories and i'm writing a single
player story and uh that's what i did
for titanfall and and that was my
expectation moving forward and when that
changed to battle royale i was like man
i didn't really do anything for the
multiplayer for titanfall so how is
story and writing gonna work in this
like a battle royale game and uh are you
guys the first to do it to have a story
focused about it
i think
i would i'll say that we were um
but because i think i
i i don't i
yeah unless there's something we don't
know we didn't have anything to lean on
um that's possible
um but that was sort of it when we
started seeing these characters uh
become more like characters than classes
i remember going around the office
telling people stop calling them classes
you're like lifeline was like the health
class and and gibraltar was defense
class and it was like they're characters
we're gonna give them names and i
remember looking up old emails not too
long ago and i found like
like the list of names and i was like we
gotta call them by names so that they
are people um and developing that and
nailing that on the head so aj shafe is
lifeline's name and that's like a name
that has stuck since the beginning and
makoa gibraltar is gibraltar's name so
his last name is still what he's his
class was called but it still makes him
a real character and once we started
doing that people started to see who
they were and um cared about wanting to
know more about their backstories and
and then uh that's so all the work that
we had to do to like set up the world
and then separate it from titanfall by
pushing it like 15 years into the future
in a distant region of where titanfall
took place and then i had to create the
lore that separated the two like a black
this thing that was not to get too deep
into it but i had to say like it was the
blackout so that we don't know about the
war of titanfall it keeps it kind of
open-ended and now we're exploring that
through our characters voices and that
is really the key overall for apex is
that everything story wise
everything um
every explanation every uh
thing that's connected to a story or the
narrative it's all told through the lens
of the character
and that means we're not explaining why
there are multiple bloodhounds in a
match um because
that's it's a video game but if we were
to explore we'd explore through the lens
of a character and how they feel about
it and um stuff like that so every time
we do choose to explain something we do
it through the lens of the character and
that helps us push narrative even more
into apex because you care about these
characters they have points of view so
sorry i'm talking a lot so that's no
that's super interesting yeah
i can't even imagine
that i'm like oh
so with a with a game like that that has
constant updates or near constant
updates it seems like how do you as a as
a writer how do you keep up with that
yeah uh so uh it takes about a
year to a year and a half to create one
character from um the creation the id
and building the whole world
and it's it's
exactly we were talking about earlier is
that it's the collaborative thing that
really comes into play because we're not
just a writer coming up with a character
and being like there it is good luck we
are coming up with the character
alongside the design of what the
prototype of the ability is one of my
favorite things about any of the kinds
of any facet of video game writing that
i've ever done i've even done like
really tiny bits of consulting is
writing something and then seeing what
an artist makes of it
every every single time that i've ever
been like oh it's art day i'm like oh
and then you see what somebody else made
and they made what you wrote way cooler
and then you take that and you make it
even better and it's just everybody's
doing cool [ __ ] on top of it to inspire
each other totally it's awesome
and that's what happens like they'll say
something and then they'll another
people and and other ideas and then
animation will come back with some sort
of cool thing and it's like well i never
even thought about that for that
character let me build that into the
story a bit yeah
you know we start um finding out what
our fantasy is of the character what the
direction of their personality is um
what they care about why are they
fighting in the games which is key um
and uh our big um we we are very much uh
uh care about the diversity inclusion
and finding ways to get that in and uh
work with all designers and artists to
find the the best version of that
character possible which um we care a
lot about it so that's why it takes so
long and then auditions and finding the
right actor that fits the role and and
we go through rounds and rounds of that
all while simultaneously writing new
lines of dialogue for every season about
a couple now we're at like thousands of
lines of dialogue
per uh
per round uh not per character like 100
or mid lines per character something
like that and then ways to tell story in
game with our conditional dialogue which
is the the unique dialogue between two
characters that changes every season
here and there um
and then we have like comics for social
media that we work with incredible
community artists on we write the lore
videos that tell the story of the brand
new character we write the gameplay
trailers with uh with our marketing team
and uh our launch trailers that have
story in them and then just anything we
can do to keep trying to innovate and
find new ways to get story and get
people to keep caring about these
characters while also changing them
along the way there's been reveals
there's been you know tweaks there's
been relationships there's been breakups
there's been you know friendships
there's been all kinds of stuff um so
it's really fun and exciting but it's
just non-stop roller coaster we gotta do
work every three months
yeah
how
mary i feel like this probably applies
to you as well with telltale how does it
feel to write something
or certain lines of dialogue that
you know someone isn't going to see
like in the case of apex it would be
if they played a different season they
don't have context of something that
would have happened prior would have
been said prior with telltale it could
be an entire subplot that just nobody
will ever see that could be your
favorite subplot like how do you
make yourself feel okay with that
um
i love it because because what they do
opt into i think players
i mean i guess not always but players
love things when they they chose this
storyline right they chose this
character they chose to be a jerk or
nice or whatever um i think it's great
it's how i got into gaming is part of it
is that my early games you know as a as
a little thing at a computer were all
bioware games i liked or yeah i liked
all the rpgs so getting to write a
telltale game um was great because uh
when players get to opt in and shape
their own characters and shape their own
stories like it they feel so much
ownership and it's so exciting um and
then you know you see all the the
youtube videos go up late it's like all
the choices that you didn't choose so
like someone will see it eventually
that's true that's true
but even if you know 0.08 percent of
players got this ending and we know
we tracked all of that but um
i i just think it's great i love writing
branching stories um because i like to
see which direction players will go in
and i like to see um the biggest thing i
like to watch for is
do players change direction because of
the story we've been telling so if we
have a storyline that's you know this
theme versus this thing it's like um
selflessness versus ruthlessness
is there at any point in the story where
we've given you enough we've given you
enough really dramatic stakes we've
given you enough characters that you're
gonna switch sides i love that um so
getting to watch stuff like that it's
just really fun it's something that only
really video games can do with our
stories so you got like a cool social
experiment
yeah
that's kind of neat push you into being
a jerk
do you watch like twitch streams to see
see it happen
and be like i got you
i love what i love i love
i love watching people do all that yeah
um because i wrote a walking dead the
thing i was proudest of writing was um
romance between clementine and violet
and watching all the streamers play
through that um was
awesome it was the first like big piece
of content i had written in a video game
and all of the twitters were like
screaming and
that's so
lovely yeah manny i feel like the
question is very different for you of
like you know a multiplayer game
i don't even know
how you approach
potentially someone having mr season and
thus missing a story or if they don't
see like the little shorts that you guys
put out which i love
then how do you
approach
knowledge for new players who could jump
in at any point in time with with
nothing yeah no i mean uh it's that's
definitely a good question and it's
something that we're trying to get
better at and and navigate um
uh it wasn't our
anticipation right at the beginning we
was like let's get story in and see if
this works and we've been constantly
putting more in and having to for
content and now we are at that point
where you know for those who aren't
caught up um
like just hoping that they go back to
see videos is not the best practice so i
think we're
we've been having discussions finding
ways to get that to find a way to
help newcomers to kind of get welcomed
into the lore um and they're they're
always working on new stuff and i think
that comes with like
stuff that we've tried and doesn't work
and stuff we tried that worked but it
was a lot of work to put in and and so
we're because we're a live service we're
able to like put something in in a
season
and then see if it hits and if it didn't
work the way we expected it then we
innovate and we innovate and we have a
loyal fan base that sticks with us along
the way and understands that we are
constantly trying to make things better
and get better at it so i you know
hopefully uh
next coming seasons some stuff like that
could show up um
maybe like you just gave me such a pr
answer which i respect well no i imagine
you do also genuinely care but like to
talk about it like for you personally
you know
writing 100 lines of dialogue
that could
disappear
is does that change the way that you
approach writing it
i think um the characters change because
of those lines so no matter when you
join the story you're gonna feel one way
about a character
eventually and then you will be on
the journey with that character as they
continue to change and develop
relationships and friendships and
and whatever with other characters and
their their world so we don't lean too
much on
all of the explaining of why they're
here and all
why they're
you know needing to do
um
join the games or
even too much of their
backstories which are fully fleshed out
but uh more on the now and with those
characters because it is a in the moment
all the time game so i think uh after
playing probably a week you'll know the
some of the friendships and then
that we next season we'll might break up
a friendship or something like that and
you'll still feel it so i think
i think the emotion can still come
across
yeah no that's totally fair um it's just
like so different to what both mary and
i do frankly it's so weird it's all it's
just a weird we're making we're figuring
it out as we go and i think in the end
if if i
i think you all feel this way it's like
if you can make someone cry in a video
game then you won
and
and we've done that and we've all done
that and it's super super gratifying i
think aaa game development as a whole is
figuring it out as we go
no not even triple h just the whole
thing the whole thing is always falling
apart and nobody knows how any of it
works so this is a thing that i think
about a lot that i'm very uh excited to
ask both of you is what do you see as
the future of video game storytelling or
are there directions that you want to
see the industry head in that it hasn't
yet
mary
oh yeah so super filled question yeah
i think about it every day
well i i might unfortunately have a
somewhat boring answer in that i think
i think people love good stories and i
think we're good at telling them like
it's not new right storytelling is not
new humans are pretty good at it they're
pretty good at being able to tell when
stories aren't amazing because because
we do it all the time shakespeare was
overrated i don't know yeah whatever
um so like
we're good at this already and then
getting to apply that to the idea of
play and different types of play and
different verbs and different fantasies
it's just an exciting time to be in
something that's constantly changing
like i feel like um
you know every time i hear oh this is
the next big thing in video games i'm
like well we did that 20 years ago like
it's not or you know 10 years ago or
five like we're just we're constantly
i don't want to say recycling because
that has a negative connotation that i
don't mean it is this we're trying out
new things and then we toss it out and
then we try something new um
i like linear single-player games i like
branching rpgs uh i like i
got into apex which i did not expect
because i cared about all the characters
like
i i think we're just applying story to
genres that traditionally haven't had
them and that's what's really exciting
about being a writer in games right now
is that more genres are going actually
having a writing team makes people care
more and then they play more um so
that's that's the biggest change i would
say is not that we're gonna see
games we've never seen before it's more
like we're gonna see games that we have
seen before but now they have stories
and writer's rooms and just really
robust character driven narratives i
mean and that is happening like
incrementally constantly is that there
are a lot of studios that don't hire
writers from the jump
you know that you didn't think that they
needed them and now that is like we keep
talking about it is a huge partnership
with design and i was actually surprised
by how much of my job at sms would be
design it's not it's not in my job title
but like i do have to think about like
okay well what does this look like
how much would that cost like i do have
to think that way all the time
and i feel like
the earlier you have a writer's team on
board and like i said more studios doing
it faster and faster than the better the
stories can be in the long term because
you know you've heard about a million
aaa studios that hired a writer's team
six months left and they're like
fix it figure it out
it makes people cry and you're like i'll
try
alrighty buddy
uh how about you maddie how do you feel
about the future of video games
storytelling uh no yeah all that is is
spot on it's definitely the i've seen
that because i was i was the first
writer full-time writer for respawn uh
no way and then it wasn't until
your uh after uh or like midway through
titanfall two or right when we launched
i forget uh but aaron contreras and
megan festival i believe the next two
brought on for fall in order so then who
wrote the first titanfall
uh me and uh steve fukuda and uh
my old uh mentor jesse stern but jesse
and i were were on contract we were not
full-time cause he was never full-time
and on titanfall 2 uh i was brought on
with stephen kudu as the game director
just to help out and then i started so i
was contract for titanfall 2. i wasn't
even full-time at that point and i and
then uh then whatever we're trying to
figure out what how i can stay at the
company i end up writing my own job
description uh so that they could hire a
full-time writer for the company
which is so wild now because we have
like
a an incredible amount of writers at the
company for all the different projects
and with vancouver uh respawn uh
bringing on their writers and it's just
it just looks like nothing but like uh
there's a mind of creative genius and
it's so cool to see that grow and feel
like you're uh everyone respects the
what writers are and writers respect
their collaboration with the other
departments yeah and so uh like barry
said like i i think the future of gaming
writing for games should be better than
it is now and it should always get
better like if it's just gonna do the
same then then why are we trying you
know uh so there is that iteration over
and over and over again but that's to
make it better and
although we're figuring it out as we go
we're also really good at what we do and
that's why we're figuring it out we're
not just figuring out to do the same
thing over and over again we're figuring
out how to do it better with writers
writer rooms with more uh voices who
haven't been heard and get them in romes
and and other types of games and and and
styles of putting story either in the
game or outside of the game with with
the comics and with uh all kinds of
stuff that people will start caring
about because it's connected to the game
it's like
the source of the game is you know
the center of it all and the comics and
the short films or whatever are all
attached to that as opposed to the
opposite where it's like you know go see
a movie and you want to play the game of
that
yeah i'm just i'm such a huge fan of of
the way that we can tell
stories in video games i mean that's
such a
bland way of phrasing that but
you know the ability to offer empathy uh
in video games is virtually unparalleled
um and i i'm on the board of uh an
organization called checkpoint which is
focused on exploring the relationship
between mental health and video games
and
i reached out to the founder jen who's
wonderful um about
the relationship between uh it was
actually around detroit become human it
was being criticized for depicting
domestic violence i think it's actually
child abuse in that game which is a
pretty serious theme
and
so i reached out to her and ended up
talking to a number of doctors about it
as well i still worked at ign and the
consensus was generally as long as this
doesn't cause harm to someone which
obviously they have to do it very
delicately uh even to a perpetrator if
they were to play this game somebody who
is committing acts of domestic violence
if they were to play a game like this
could potentially feel empathy that
they've never seen before because
they've never seen what they themselves
are doing and i don't think that that's
something that you can necessarily have
in films and tv or even in a book where
you can put somebody in the shoes and
make them make the decisions and watch
the reactions it's like we have a lot of
uh
potentially really positively impactful
power through the way that that video
game storytelling unfolds and and you
know the things that you can make the
players do and that's why like i'm not
scared of horror movies at all
terrified of horror games like
real baby about it yeah yeah because
you're doing it and i think that that
opens up so much more creative freedom
obviously environmental storytelling you
know that's a thing that you you can't
necessarily do in any other medium
without forcing a camera on something
which does that make it environmental
storytelling that kind of makes an
exposition
i just feel like we have so much
creativity that i i always think
we've see we haven't seen everything yet
you know there are things that we do do
amazingly well i also love bioware games
i'd be surprised if many people didn't
uh and have such a soft spot for them
but i feel like that one of the beauty
beautiful things about video games is
that we don't actually know how far we
can go because the hardware's just not
even
we're limited we genuinely don't know
you could potentially have a full new
york city with a million npcs in it at
some point
um and what can we do with that i have
no idea let's find out in 50 years see
who makes it first and who can figure
out how to do it without spending too
much money and i just feel like that's
so exciting and so cool like knowing how
limited we are right now versus what we
will be able to do because of the
limitless technology that is at our
disposal it's just super exciting i'm
like this is a very big fan of video
game storytelling so to jump jump
directly off of that can i ask you both
what do you think is the best video game
story i want to say ever written but i
don't like the way i'm phrasing that
that's too boxed in you tell me what's
your favorite video game story or what
do you think is the best
and why
wow super rude i know softball question
after softball question i know i like to
keep my guests relaxed here
yeah
should feel like a vacation yeah
our favor to what we think is the best i
kind of want you to give me both okay
because they are two different things
i would nominate hellblade as being very
high up there
uh it's definitely like my top five yeah
not top three it's so beautifully
written in addition to being beautifully
designed and it's beautiful whatever
it's great i think portal 2 is probably
the best game ever made and i i i stand
by that with the story as well
but i'm now realizing i don't even have
an answer to my own question i feel like
i would submit hellblade as as best
currently just in terms of how
well
the story and the design do go together
um and before the game came out people
not knowing what happened if you died in
that game made it extra exciting in
terms of like this tension and gameplay
that was delivered by
the narrative i thought was very good
i would put what remains to be dispensed
in there
same thing
the mechanics unique to each character
the storytelling of each character the
theme was really strong it's beautifully
written and almost no cut scenes it is
uh it is stories told through gameplay
which is hard to do and something i
really love right right yeah yeah and i
like that they leaned into those unique
mechanics like none of them were you
know it's not these complex systems or
anything but um you know it's it's more
than a walking sim it's walking in doing
all these other things doesn't one of
them
have you just like cut fish
that is the thing right i'm like
forgetting what they all are and it
wrecked my life so they didn't get crazy
that was one of the most depressing ones
i remember the both
um i remember the one that looks like a
heart like yeah it was a good game got
me really good yeah
um swinging back and forth uh
yeah
you turn into a cat at one point
yeah there's a lot going on there
there's a lot happening yeah it was it
was not simple i'm just like looking at
a gameplay trailer now and being like oh
man yeah i forgot about that too
yeah
yeah it's super creative
it's probably kind of a basic answer or
like an answer that you've heard a
million times but like i still reference
the last of us constantly not
necessarily even in my day-to-day work
but in when like i said i'm teaching
this narrative design class and it comes
up constantly of just like
lessons that they learned things that we
could build on things you know there's
just there's a lot of good stuff in
there to learn from so i'm i'll toss
that one in the ring and how much of a
risk that was for naughty dog as well
like it was so different for me so
different i wonder what that pitch
meeting look like
for them to be like here's what we're
making and it's gritty and they're like
no you're the crash bandicoot studio
what are you doing how are we going to
market this
and they were like in zombies and
they're like no
it's just so different like for them to
even take that that leap and for it to
pay off that well i mean i i fully think
that that is one of the best video game
endings we've ever had and i know um
neil i think says
he doesn't care if people hate it
doesn't care people love it he just
doesn't want people to not care he
doesn't want indifference and like
totally i don't think you've got
indifference from that ending no matter
what like people
it means a lot the ending in that game
for sure i have a personal relationship
to when i explain tried to explain to my
family that i was going to be a video
game writer of course they were like
they're going to be a what a who what is
that
so i showed them the opening of of the
last of us
that's a really good idea yeah
uh maddie i'm not letting you off the
hook though what's your name uh i mean
it's it's it's not not an easy answer
for me because i
i am my
stories gravitate more towards tv and
film when i do references in rooms than
other games got a lot of those in our
writer's rooms too i have a list of uh
movies i've had to catch up on yeah uh
but uh
something i thought was really cool was
half-life alex because what i liked was
that
it gave me a character that i knew and
did kind of care about without knowing
that i
wanted to be that person but also
putting me in a world where i felt okay
not having some of the journey that i
wasn't getting over the past half-lifes
that i had gone through
and it just kind of dropped me in the
middle of this and i i gave a [ __ ] about
everything kind of right away uh and
then it had this uh
this this sweet just
journey of uh
um
relationship between her and her father
and where that goes to with the ending
and the choices that she makes just made
me like
i don't know it was just something
interesting when i was playing that i
i stopped caring that i cared so much
about the other games and i felt like
this was like
like all i cared about and i thought
that somehow just looking at that i'm
like that was a seemed weird of a choice
to kind of have to say that so to be
like we're gonna do this game without
gordon freeman and without uh you know
the all this the concluding what we had
just gone through all before and just
started something fresh um
it really got robbed because of the
platform that not a lot of people spoke
about it i was really surprised you
didn't get game of the year nominations
like across the board but i bought an
oculus just for it i love oculus i'm
such a fan
it's so good and yeah it is it is really
really good and i've actually not
finished it i really should go back and
finish it oh yeah thank you for not
spoiling it
yeah you'll uh it's fun fun journey um
and then i also like uh reference uh
uncharted 4 because there's this moment
that i i do reference in the thing that
was
the um that we call the nexus which is
this moment when gameplay character and
the player all are in sync with what the
story is and where what they're doing um
and i i always reference that moment uh
where nathan drake is in the attic and
he's just
bored and he's just playing with a toy
and right when he picks up the toy the
music kicks on and it's like feels like
you're in a combat situation but you
know you're in an attic and you're just
playing with a toy gun and shooting
targets and it's gameplay fun like yeah
this is how i shoot
and the music makes me that experience
uh the character
is in it right there but then we know
like shortly after that he just feels
sad that he's not on this adventure
anymore and that his daily life is just
to kind of be at home and not not not
out there
he kills a bunch of people
but uh you know but me as a player is
also like
ah i'm stuck in this attic i want to go
in the jungle and i want to do more
climbing and stuff like that and go on
an adventure so in that moment i feel
like the player and the character and
the gameplay is all in sync and that's
like the definition of a nexus for me
and it's like now whatever nathan drake
does moving forward if it's
in the the feeling of of what was
established in that scene i will be on
board with it because i i will do
whatever it takes to not be in an addict
with the toy guy because you're coming
from the same place i mean i think they
did a fantastic job of that in the last
part too as well where that game keeps
going
and i was like i want this to be done
why is it still going then i was like oh
my god they all feel the same way yeah
like at first i was like it's dragging
and then i was like of course it is
because it's dragging for [ __ ]
everybody my god it's like i've been
bamboozled
yeah and charlotte's got a lot of really
great examples like that like is it is
it three or four that has that big
market
that's like
the amount of market yeah foreign amount
of lines of dialogue
yeah yeah
so cool and the research that went into
making sure that all felt authentic and
it turns out naughty dog pretty good at
what they do
yeah i mean i also really love the story
and go to what 2018 which naturally i
did not work on
absolutely zero bias um but i i must put
that out there especially the moment of
when hmm how do i say this without
spoiling um when you can't fire arrows
anymore that whole sequence wow way to
just punch me in the face with that just
by taking a button away but not taking
it away off the menu just grain it out
similar kind of necklace moment
yeah where you feel the way
the character feels and i think that
game does that quite a few times and
yeah yeah it is i've never heard of it
called a nexus moment before but i like
that that totally steve i think yeah
steve fakuda the game director for
titanfall
coined that term for us i think i don't
know if he got it from someone else but
that's what he always called it the
nexus and i always try to relate that to
characters and writing for games it's
like making sure that i care the same
amount as my character cares at least in
a parallel it doesn't need to i don't
need to care about the character's
specific sister or brother that they're
trying to go after whatever but i can
understand and relate to them on some
sort of level um of at least that
feeling uh yeah i think there's
something important about that in games
and something that can only happen in
games exactly what you're saying of like
movie and film that tv and film can't do
this
because i still know that i'm watching
that person cry i am not crying
in the moment because of an action i
made and if you can
actually get that nexus to work you will
be the one crying because of the action
you made or actually someone else made
to that character and yeah that's what
makes it it's a lot of power
a lot of power but also a lot of
challenge and and that's gonna lead me
to my next question which is you know i
won't take up too much more time um what
is the hardest thing about your job
what is the hardest thing
about being a video game writer and
especially if it's something you think
people don't expect
i think it is trying to find
the right mechanics to get those moments
with the player that are so crucial um
to me
someone else might find that the easiest
part of the job but um and i mean that
is a collaboration between design and
writing and art usually and sound
department you know it's everybody has
to do that
but
again we're we're using tools that are
still pretty new right like this idea of
taking a button off off of the map
because because a character is not
around anymore things like that are
still pretty new to storytelling so it's
not it's not immediately obvious like
how do we make
the player angry because the player
character is angry how do we make them
feel the struggle how do we make them
feel protective it's not just writing
it's also what are the mechanics we're
throwing at them how can we tweak it how
can we make it so this feels that way
for every type of player not just the
kind that plays in this certain way
um
it's challenging but it is also the most
thrilling part of what we do because
that i mean that's why we do so much
play testing right is this working are
we getting them in the right head space
are we getting the right reactions um
and it's it's great it's good narrative
design but it's not easy to pull off and
it takes a long time and a lot of people
a lot of people a lot of play testing
yep
maddie how about you yeah there's
something about that like the reaction
of knowing that things might not work
the way you want it
and needing to push that sort of like
push your ego aside or push the what
you're what you thought was right and
being able to push that aside just to
listen and see what other people say and
being able to
collaboratively work uh
to make it a new version of that work
because the thing in games is things get
cut all the time things get changed all
the time like something that's cool at
least for us is always takes you know
precedent it's always we we would care
more about something that is not present
prior uh and something that someone
comes up with that's like this is a
really cool idea
we're gonna do it
and you need to figure it out and rather
than trying to fight with them you find
ways to try to make it work and i think
that's sort of how
um
uh uh
we developed this the conditional
dialogue system where characters are
able to talk to each other and that was
something that like we always wanted to
do and tom castillo one of our old
writers was wanting to try to find ways
to to get a a actual moment in the game
where
uh revenant and loba were like fighting
on the same team but they're both like
enemies of each other and it just feels
weird if they're not
talking
unique lines to each other if they were
just like you know friendly or generic
lines so um just having to to to get
buy-in and find ways to make it feel
like that is and
how we can uh address that kind of
brought the idea of
getting a designer on board and having
them say hey we've been come up with
this cool idea of where we could do
unique dialogue and it's like wait this
could work perfect for this revenant
loba thing and oh we'll find ways to
prototype it and and so it's not like
freaking out and being like oh this
game's it's never gonna work i'm done
it's just trusting in your your
collaborators that that we can all make
the best version possible and and
sometimes you can
really get in your head about that i
think
it's a big task i think one of the
coolest things about working in video
games in general is like a massive
luxury that we have is
everybody else being excited
like you're all working towards this one
goal where you all want the thing to be
as good as possible and you're all just
like all right great idea let's figure
it out let's make it better and it's
just it's it's so cool like it's just so
cool to be able to get to work with like
really creative smart people who can
solve problems that you didn't even know
were problems by virtue of like their
specific kind of expertise on teams of
300 plus people you know it's
it's a good time
another part of my answer on the
challenge thing because there's so many
um
the other biggest challenge i think for
specifically for game writers is
the outdated belief
that you hit pause on gameplay so you
can do some story you hit pause on story
so you can do some game play
rinse repeat and that's how games are
made and very against it i ever like
everybody gets it whether they know it
or not
yeah that's true
nobody wants to play through a whole
level that doesn't have any narrative
content and no emotional payload it
feels like a checklist so they can get
to a cut scene and on the flip side
other players who love the checklist
part but hate watching cut scenes don't
want to have to sit through you know
like that's not that's not
all of us working together to make a
full experience where the player feels
like they're in the shoes of this player
character that's just we do this and
then we do this and we do this
that's probably what it looks like if
the teams are really separate honestly
yeah just another throw cut scene in
there i don't know
i've mostly encountered that when i was
freelancing and it would i mean
obviously
writer being like hey could you just
throw some scripts over the fence and
i'm like i mean sure
but
but they're not going to be as good
because i'm not talking designer about
where where this stuff you know triggers
you can't have the impact yeah
yeah it's a fine balance um well i guess
off of that question then what's your
favorite thing
about your job what's the best thing
about getting it right is it crazy to
say that the
favorite thing is the hardest thing
because i think there's that's where i
find that our
cool innovative and amazing ideas uh uh
come out of those challenges that
totally um knock us down because uh
i i feel like that's some of the
greatest stuff that we've come up with
has come from um uh an example here is
we had we were testing out like a pve
and we did this whole pve thing where uh
we're collecting and they're separate
from the br and it was a broken this
broken ghost story that we had with like
these chapters and it felt really cool
and there was a lot of work put into it
but we were starting to get the story
going and then we had to uh we weren't
able to continue pve because of how much
work that went into it it wouldn't be
something we will be able to pull off
every single season but we had these
story lines set up and because the pva
pve aspect changed uh after we had
already launched the first version we
had to find a way to conclude it
and that's what ended up kicking us off
these conversations with um
uh alex zuckerman and about how our
community
is really uh amazing fan art and that we
can collaborate with them to develop
fan community made uh comics and we
still do this to today we just dropped
one today and uh that would have never
happened if pve didn't change your
comics are community made
the ones that we post on twitter are all
community arts that's really cool
they're all
fans of the game they're all incredible
artists and uh we uh connect with them
and then we contract them to do uh
specific uh that's awesome pages they
work with a writer um so our writers
write it but we work with the artists um
so all those ones yeah i have no idea
that's the coolest like because then
you're also like helping people build
their portfolios and absolutely yeah
and we also get to work when you are a
writer assigned to a comic story with an
artist like they're involved in the
process and and their input is just as
valid as uh someone else's input so when
we're talking about the story like
they're included in that and there's
been some uh
choices and ideas that that have come
about that felt really uh inspiring to
the writers and then the writers inspire
back to those community artists and um
yeah they're all very very talented so
getting to work one-on-one with those
artists is is really cool yeah that
rules i just looked up some of the art
and it's all very horrible yeah there's
no way i had absolutely no idea that
that's awesome i mean i know insomniac
recently hired
like a social
person uh i'm not sure if the community
manager is the right title but i had so
many friends who went for that job
and uh loads of them like loads of
people i know who've been in the
industry for a long time and then
insomniac ended up hiring a fan and i
was like
hey as a community manager like i
respect the hell out of that like they
they didn't go with you know the person
who was running ig and social for have a
long and whatever else like they went
with a fan and i was like that's like
suits insomniac's brand 100 like i hired
uh
recently about like five six months ago
i hired a fan to be our uh our lore
historian for oh yeah
titanfall
uh yeah uh uh david barrow aka frozenfro
was our uh uh person who just kept
tweeting every day about all the lore
that we've had and was uh running the
apex floor subreddit and when we were
getting to the point where we needed to
start uh having some help you know
grabbing all the lore of all the stuff
that we have we ended up bringing him on
board to
help with our uh our uh narrative
archives that's i could have a whole
separate podcast conversation about that
is that we are currently trying to hire
an associate archivist
which is
it's just such a task that
before working at a triple a studio i
wouldn't have known that you needed is
somebody who can compile everything and
tell you where everything is and pull
the correct version of the thing and
like give you like
it's amazing that that anybody functions
without knocking us like for any big
property it's wild
i don't know how we did it that way we
have jonah gerber and uh and david and
they both are
i don't know how we did it without them
it's huge it's wild
um mary what's your answer to the
question of your favorite thing
uh my favorite thing
a couple things um that are all
connected the first is when a script
finally works like you've just been
you've been going you've been trying to
get this cinematic or this gameplay
script or whatever and it's just
it doesn't feel good it's not working
it's not great and it finally comes
together and you show it to the rest of
the team and they like it that's that's
just uh i did it finally
um another one is when a scene
that i've written when the music goes in
hmm oh yeah it always hits me every time
i just one once the scores that like
everything else is wonderful seeing the
actors acting scenes i assume you don't
you don't talk to the composers you
don't speak with them directly i don't
speak directly the composer but i do
speak i mean i work with the audio
department really closely on like you
know talking about like mixes and stuff
but but the score is usually surprised
so that's the biggest difference right
is that like with everything else i've
at least been around talking to the
animators i was on the pcap stage i was
talking to you so like i kind of know
but when the score goes in i haven't
heard it yet so when i see that
the first time i usually cry because you
know i'm gonna be a snap forever
so the final one is just like
when we announce or when we ship scene
fans reactions is legitimate like i
still watch all of them i watched them
from games i made years ago when i need
to pick me
uh
when wolverine was announced i watched
everybody i watched the internet catch
on fire and it was awesome you caught
them on fire
yeah congratulations
i was sitting right here like going like
this
i did that with ragnarok i went and
watched a bunch of people reacting to
the trailer it was it was very very cool
like and the thing that got me was the
people who recognized everybody's names
and like knew who they were and i was
like oh you know these people the way i
know these people like that is
just very very cool to get to see i look
forward to watching people play through
it it's gotta be pretty surreal
ryan hurst is one of my favorites so i
very good but very
yeah he's not bad he's not bad no that's
all i'll say yeah yeah
all right he's not gonna i'm not gonna
steal oh yeah go ahead yeah one thing is
that you did remind me of something i
don't i don't like to be negative but
there is a one part that that i do want
to point out that is a good warning for
writers is that um
in regards to the we do work very
closely with the audio team and one of
the challenges is when attempt dialogue
gets in the game and i always feel like
every other dev doesn't put a dev goggle
on when temp dialogue is in the game and
you can get a lot of
harsh feedback yeah because it's totally
just temp dialogue and we do work very
very closely with the audio department
pretty much every day and
to get actual voice actors in takes a
time and a process and um
so we uh
i remember going through that journey of
like there's there's just people around
the office who are feeling in for
characters because they had to and it's
like we didn't change a line of dialogue
uh and they hated the character when
they heard the tech dialogue and and
then they're obsessed with the character
when we got the voice actor which is to
say that voice actors are really good
and um but it is that is something that
can really like
make you feel like you didn't do
anything great it's it's a weird thing
it's a really hard thing to find a
solution to though because yeah if you
listen to temp dialogue it can ruin a
scene it can make it really funny yeah
because it's so dorky
if you're on i mean i've been on a few
comedy games now and everyone's like why
aren't your jokes funny
i'm the one reading them
it's definitely a struggle that is a
really good point yeah i mean my
favorite thing about about what i get to
do is is 100
working with people who are way smarter
than me and who have a wealth of
knowledge that i will never have and
that i have the tremendous privilege of
even being able to be around them to be
like okay you're an absolute expert on
this field that i i
couldn't do anything even remotely close
to that and you've been doing it for a
decade and i get to talk to you about
that
like i just i just love like the the
passion and experience that is just
rife
like throughout santa monica studios
just so so many people at the top of
their game who are just so smart who and
who are always willing to answer
questions too like it's just it's i've
never had anyone be like i don't have
time if i have a question they're always
like
this i'm like cool thank you and it's
just like
awesome like just being around smart
people all the time and being like i
will learn what i can and i will respect
that you are so much smarter than me and
i love that for me it's great
but of course you know all the other
stuff too it's all good
um all right thank you guys so much for
joining me this is very fun i could talk
to you both uh for a lot longer i think
again i could talk about offices for
half an hour yeah thank you for joining
me
um mary where can people find you
you can usually find me on twitter at uh
mary kay news is my handle is usually
where i'm around um
apart from that i also have a website
marykaygames.com that has all my other
press interviews contact that's all
there
maddie how about you
yeah i'm on the twitter i think that's
mostly the only place uh at manny
agopian and um i mostly just tweet fart
jokes so nice
keep it up yeah i will leave links in
the description to both of your twitters
so people can go say hi
if they want to um but thank you guys
for joining me thank you so much for
watching of course
[Music]
[Music]
you